but for me the most important thing is
the safety and the security of the
people
uh for for people to go in anywhere
any social event they have whether it's
football
whether it's a theater whether it's uh
whether it's in the pubs or whatever if
it's possible to know that the people
are coming in there
have a clean bill of health then i think
they must be advantageous to everybody
and i think the great work that they've
done so far
within vaccinations um it's been
fantastic and it'd be a shame to
be careless and throw all this away with
where we
desire because people have a great
desire to go and get back into
what they call a normal way of life but
i think it's got a safer
for me if i get tested and i was
negative and i knew it and somewhere
i'd be happy with that because at the
end of the day i don't want to be
passing
covered or any people around about me
and you never know what faith's got now
waiting on me to catch you
what do you think of these mps then who
are concerned about privacy issues the
government potentially snooping into
people's lives with covert passports
well as long as it's plenty there you
can't get anything out of it
uh all you can get out is information
are the premises
and that's your photo id your ticket
number
and whether you're the test that you
took was positive or negative
i mean everyone everybody's got an
option they can make their choices if
they don't want to go
and get a test then they don't go but
then if you don't have a test and it's
it makes it difficult for me voting the
mighties in a clear
clear state of mind lewis what about the
uh
comparative cost of what you're offering
with what some of the other alternatives
that are being talked about
can you offer this fairly cheaply at a
cost effective uh
price for for example bar and restaurant
operators
so it's actually free for everybody to
use
so you don't have to pay to use our
service you can get a free passport
you just have to assign your own test to
it right
how do you make money out of it if it's
free uh we make money out of the the
clinics themselves so we will be making
money out of testing but not the
passport itself
right so kelly what about uh the players
themselves professional sports people
what do you think it's been
like playing behind closed doors all
this time does does it have an impact on
performance do you think
yeah well it affects a lot of people uh
in different ways
certainly at liverpool defines it's
hugely important and beneficial
to the performances and results the
teams get on the pitch
and i think maybe for us it suffered the
players have suffered a little bit
because the fans aren't there
and also it works to the benefit of the
the team when the opposition are getting
a bit of abuse from
our own supporters so i think it does
help but
i think it was fantastic when it came
back at first because
we'd gone we'd gone short on it we
haven't watched it for a long time
but the longer you watch it without any
crowds and
the less appealing i think it becomes
you know so far
when they had the the experiment with
the 2000 fans coming in
they didn't have to make a difference it
sounds strange but 2
000 people in the 50 000 stadium but
they certainly made themselves head
and i think it adds to the atmosphere
but the atmosphere and going to the
football
it's not just about attending the match
it's the social side of it as well
around about it and it needs to be saved
before we can get all the numbers back
we're gonna be back to square one i
think absolutely completely agree with
you now
there's been a lot of commentary in the
press over the weekend about the
possibility of some scotland fans being
allowed into wembley for the uh
euros this summer you'd be right behind
that i presume
well they're right behind scotland uh
if the fans can get there that would be
brilliant but as i said earlier i think
safety and security is the most
important thing and we don't want to
spoil the work that's going ahead
it's this stage after a year we're
getting a wee bit more positive news out
of
places but scotland england
is always a huge attraction and it seems
to be more attractive for the scottish
supporters when they go to wembley yeah
i remember putting one through ray
clements's legs
way back when um what about liverpool
tonight they're playing real madrid in
the in the champions league quarter
final you're fairly optimistic
i'm always optimistic um as i say
there's a great performance and result
once on saturday against wolverhampton
against mohammed
and the three-nil victory so for me it's
that
i'm looking forward to the game in real
madrid
uh obviously they don't know the force
that they have been over the years so
it's still a difficult game for us but
it's one that
we don't need one but if we're still in
the game comedy and fuel that it could
be
it could be important in the world do
you think liverpool are going to make it
to the semis
well hopefully maybe even make it
to the finals at the top stadium one of
the finest
finals in liverpool's history when they
went there and
and beat ac milan coming back for three
now down winning the current penalty so
i'll be a bit romantic but it'd be
brilliant if you could do it again there